welcome everyone back to tick-tock what
are the tick-tock kids up to gee I
wonder better watch a PewDiePie video
why does anyone watch me for some I
don't listen first of all I don't get it
either
for some reason this clip is getting
popular Wow why this flip is so weird
let me just take a little sleeping sikri
oh my G oh wow you would do club I don't
know the breaking lyrics how does he do
it how does a man look so attractive and
yet so disgusting
alright let's let's check out some more
tick tock God how does he even keep them
bare let me tell you about my favorite
drink G fuel G fuel has their biggest
sale ever
not 20% not 25% no not 30% of 31% uh-huh
oh because that's bigger than Brad's
discount so if you enter the car beauty
pie that's right Brad you get 31% of GP
you'll not two measly 30% pathetic there
are three new starter kits available to
the dolphin
inspired by Miami Dolphin the black
mamba inspired by the LA Lakers and the
Shamrock search be inspired by another
sports fan I don't know who it is Boston
Celtx
[Music]
enter code PewDiePie what are you doing
it's a great drink I enjoy it and so
might you give it a try
change lives nice watch them take tops I
didn't say that I didn't say that yeah
you did yeah you did say that though hey
guys I know you're in front of this
sleepover but uh it's time for bed okay
dad
you got it dude good night mr. Johnson
all right guys lights out every single
sleepover ever
yeah it's not a sleepover if someone
doesn't say penis in some shape or form
will now begin the push-up section ready
begin down up one down up two down god
damn it it's not your life you lose so I
can laugh but I don't want to okay
that's the thing with these tic TOCs are
like just funny enough
hey bro weird question but if you get a
shirt that's buy one get one free and
you get the other shirt but you just
return the other shirt do you get a free
shirt and your money back oh my god my
house harwood wants to know your
location and then you can repeat that
for infinity loop and get infinity
t-shirts
speaking of t-shirts now you can or
there's a 90 million club merch everyone
that's right if you want to look this
cool check out represent concise
PewDiePie 90 million club merged we lost
oh yeah they passed for like ten minutes
and that was eight but it was only to
make them cry that's right I just looked
at myself in the viewfinder and Jesus
Christ I look good I got everyone is
making fun of this guy for filling in
his eyebrows meanwhile every single girl
do it all the time and they literally
look like I do right now it's like it's
not a good look I don't know why girls
keep doing it this is how y'all ladies
look like when you overfill your
eyebrows okay you ain't
there's no eyebrows on fleek all right
you just look like me and that's not a
compliment
just a random gamer thought thought I'd
share with you guys just a random gamer
thought about random gamer thought
oh we had the car locked we were locked
down the car with the car keys in the
car and I will pull the window down
wired headphones up I am a Boy Scout
legend I love Boy Scouts guys dead I
mean that's not as impressive what more
do you want
you better not copy strike cuz I can can
I copy strike someone if they wearing my
merch probably with the way YouTube
works thank you very much for making it
easy for me to make this video ten
minutes as always and also a shame for
me to chain leaves me plug my merch yet
again that's right two times one video
maybe a third keep watching guys I was
watching this video and I noticed
something and I want to see if any of
you guys can catch it right now I have
another sentence on my brain imprinted
whenever someone's gonna say it I'll
just immediately go to the meme reaction
anyone say hey did you miss Aisha it's
not my word says everyone I like a big
leg up to the bathroom I don't know some
people just be smart like that I wish I
knew that when I was in school did we
say that in school in Sweden can you go
to the truck and your fool book it to us
I guess we never had that issue in
Sweden stupid Americans can I go to the
bathroom
[Music]
legendary yes I'll give you a sample
just so you know how it's made right in
three what are you stupid
oh no I'm sorry
hey come on man here it's one for the
good those good old time sakes I love
that clip so much I'm so glad let Reggie
left us with this beautiful click it
really just is a relatable clip that can
be applied to any situation these are so
weird oh my god yes I mean it's not a
bad look like I look like hang some
Squidward
any day son any day too bad he doesn't
have the butt cheek I do have that boat
oil I think we're pretty set here thank
you
well sure champ you can tell me anything
what is it dad I'm gay No
why did you have to phrase it like that
I want to be supportive show him I love
him if I can't hold it I have to say it
dad
hi gay I'm dad every single minute a new
picture from God is markiplier from the
future at a time in a really interesting
way I've been tracking this sucker for
years some of the pictures here are
amazing now I kind of think tick tock
fans would like it ok thank you mark
apply from the future wait what was he
talking about if you guys have never
seen a human clock before the human
clock
where's the clunk oh it's 3:30 oh my god
that's really cool the parts 330 of
course oh man
so it doesn't just scan online or has it
just collected people holding these
numbers why is she holding that this is
so weird
why what is this
and the clock is 331 what that's really
dope oh my god I mean I guess with how
many Internet's there are how many
Internet's there are yes that's what I
try to sing but it's so random though
like what that Thank You markiplier from
the future damn this is my voice two
days after watching TV PI this is my
voice
four days after watching this is the
perfect pronunciation for Laura oh my
god Jesus Christ studi pi is exactly 29
years old
that's right weird PewDiePie has exactly
nine letters in it
oh that's Korean letters only to repeat
today it's no coincidence 19 was born on
pi day back in 1879 PewDiePie
it was born in 1989 the only number that
these years don't have in common
yeah number seven number of letters that
T Siri has and their names we've
recently mentioned together beside seven
because no one cares about a random
letter okay it's convenient
that is the exact number of subscribers
if I has at this exact moment whoa did I
just hit 89 for 20 damn that's happy
that's the number of sex okay guys it is
time for me to leave hope you guys
enjoyed this video smash like and
subscribe
[Music]
what cheaper simulators becoming
relevant no no don't leave
no please sponsor Eagle please do
something yes this game is still
relevant god dammit